reese witherspoon emotionally recalls
being sexually assaulted at 16 years old
[Music]
on monday the Oscar winner attended
Elle's 24th annual women in Hollywood
celebration in Los Angeles with her 18
year-old daughter Ava in tow inside the
event the big little eyes star delivered
an emotional speech referencing the
sexual misconduct allegations against
movie mogul Harvey Weinstein and
admitting it had been a really hard week
for women in Hollywood that forced many
to quote relive a lot of ugly truths the
41 year old then recalled her own
mistreatment as a young actress saying
she had guilt for not speaking up
earlier quote I feel true disgust at the
director who assaulted me when I was 16
years old and anger at the agents and
the producers who made me feel that
silence was a condition of my employment
and while that was the first time
Witherspoon remembers being sexually
assaulted she admitted that it wasn't
the last adding that she was inspired to
tell her story after seeing so many
women speak out about their own painful
experiences quote I actually felt less
alone this week than I have ever felt in
my entire career
you can only heal by telling the truth
you